[Music]  Harry Styles debut solo album just  dropped and it seems like BBC Radio 1  has already figured out which track is  about his ex Taylor Swift oh the one  about Taylor Swift we call it two girls  meters but I'm going to capital to go  already oh [ __ ]  if you miss that the song is called two  ghosts dish to go swimming in a glass  half empty  trying to remember how it reserved a  heart  I think it's pretty like  self-explanatory is that yeah  it's about sometimes things change  yeah and you can be you know do all the  same things sometimes it's just  different you know some of the lyrics  seem to be a direct response to Taylor's  style listen  [Music]  into  my lips red same eyes blue  [Music]  same watch a couple more tattoos snow  you missed on me then get me in trouble  I don't I can tell you mansion bow with  a capital T right  [Music]